mais d'abord ces français qui ne sont
toujours pas intéressé par la
présidentielle à onze jours du premier
tour avec samia de chiens à chaque
élection présidentielle les français
désertent un peu plus les urnes en 10
ans le taux de participation a lentement
chuté de six points jusqu'à la dernière
élection et cette année il pourrait être
encore bien plus bas un sondage d'harris
interactive pour challenge publié
aujourd'hui estiment que 31 % des
électeurs ne se déplaceront pas au
premier tour même le record historique
de la présidentielle de 2002 avec ses
28,4 pour son abstention n'était pas
tombé aussi bas ça serait un record
absolu d'intention à l'élection
présidentielle on est dans un contexte
où il ya une campagne électorale qui
entre guillemets ne prend pas avec des
français qui ont également le sentiment
que l'affairé pliée si vous me permettez
l'expression c'est à dire que emmanuel
macron de toute façon gagnera la
prochaine élection présidentielle c'est
la certitude aujourd'hui de plus de
seafrance et sionistes que nous sommes
amenés interrogé pour challenges
perturbé par la guerre en ukraine
la campagne a démarré très tardivement
aînés laisser émerger aucun thème fort
assez clivant pour mobiliser l'électorat
mais tout peut encore changer il reste
encore tout genre de campagne donc on ne
peut pas prédire quand on aura une
participation aussi basses en 2017 on
avait un chiffre un tout petit peu plus
importants quelques points au dessus
mais il y avait une très forte hausse
des derniers jours de campagne en plus
c'est une campagne qui pour l'instant
n'a pas eu encore
un acte n'a pas suscité un intérêt très
important pour l'instant il est possible
que dans les 12 derniers jours en et une
hausse importante du nombre de personnes
qui nous déclarent qu'ils sont qu'elles
sont certaines d'aller voter ces
abstentionnistes forme un réservoir de
voix important pour marine le pen et
jean luc mélenchon les deux outsideurs
les mieux placés derrière emmanuel
macron ont tous deux un électorat
populaire plus susceptibles de
s'abstenir
voilà l'ascension ce sera le premier
thème de ce débat je présente mes
invités
emilie zapolsky bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes communiquant de politique jérôme
sainte-marie bonsoir bienvenue la
sondeurs politologues président de
l'institut pôle inbox jean garrigues
bonsoir sur l'argent guerre l'aigle
historiens prison il commit d'histoire
parlementaire hauteur de la tentation du
sauveur c'est aux éditions payot et
matthieu croissandeau bonsoir mathieu
bonsoir militaris politique à mes côtés
les lundis et mercredis dans ce sens
public allez on commence par analyser le
ce désintérêt qui semble se confirmer
études d'opinion après études d'opinion
et millsap à skis comment vous
l'analysez vous ce désintérêt des jeux
parce qu'il ya plusieurs éléments il ya
la gare en ukraine quand même qu'un qui
a brouillé un petit peu les pistes qui a
empêché comme le s'était dit là dans le
reportage qui a empêché de parler un peu
des sujets vraiment dont on parle
habituellement en campagne donc ça ça à
brouiller les pistes il ya aussi l'effet
drapeau il ya le côté emmanuel macron
qui est aux manettes chef des armées un
peu la prime aux sortants on veut on
veut rester dans la continuité on veut
continuer avec celui qui est aux
manettes actuellement donc voila et puis
ce qui était dit c'est à dire qu'on a
l'impression que c'est un peu joué
d'avancé même si on s'est un petit peu
que ça bouge au second et les derniers
sondages n'ont qu'une marine ne traînant
aussi un peu l'idée pourquoi ça serait
intéressant d'aller voter alors que ça
va rien changer moi je pense qu'il ya
aussi un aspect qu'il faut quand même
voir c'est l'aspect des jeunes parce que
j'ai l'impression qu'on les oublie
beaucoup dans cette campagne on les
oublie beaucoup tout le temps en fait on
les a oubliés pendant qu vide on les
oublie très généralement on voit un jean
luc mélenchon là dans son dernier
meeting à marseille qui a commencé à
parler écologie cd thème quand même qui
intéresse les jeunes qui a parlé de
l'école qui a parlé de l'éducation qui a
parlé de l'enseignement supérieur mais
c'est vrai qu'on s'adresse très peu à
eux après dans toute cette abstention ce
qui peut rappeler qu et du monde et dans
les indécis c'est ce sur quoi marine le
pen vend beaucoup son programme c'est le
pouvoir d'achat parce que c'est la
question centrale et même la gare en
ukraine nous ramène à ça avec les prix
de l'énergie les prix de l'essence avec
tous les questions pour l'année
prochaine est ce qu'on aura de
l'électricité du gaz tout le monde
regarde son portefeuille on s'en
rappelle de la crise qu vide on rentre
dans la crise ukrainienne et toutes ses
compétences toutes ses conséquences sur
l'économie et le social est probablement
ça ça peut interpeller les gens marine
le pen martel très très fort ce thème
depuis très longtemps elle est assez
crédible sur le sujet et ça ça peut
solliciter les gens parce que finalement
emmanuel macron même s'il a distribué
beaucoup pendant la crise qu vide et là
il fait encore des chèques avec
l'ukraine finalement ça n'imprime pas
tellement on voit toujours un petit peu
le président des riches donc peut-être
que marine le pen elle a un petit peu
d'avancé là dessus et puis les 15 ou 18
centimes parce que ça dépend des
départements qui vont être défalquée on
on s'en rendra compte au moment de payer
c'est à dire que quand on fait le plein
on verra le prix et puis au moment de
payer aux irakiens ces 18 centimes de
moins donc on voit bien la volonté aux
politiques qu'il ya derrière mais c'est
toujours comme ça jérôme sainte marie
c'est à dire que quand tu as un
gouvernement fait entre guillemets un
cadeau il est oublié aussi sec donc sur
le pouvoir d'achat pourquoi les l'argent
dépensé par le gouvernement ou par
emmanuel macron depuis des mois
finalement n'imprime pas dans l'esprit
ou pas suffisamment esprits des français
d'après vous une part les gens se sont
pas forcément enrichi il ya eu des gens
bien sûr vinci l'érable il a été fait
par l'état pour maintenir à flot des
petites sociétés et les individus les
salariés et c'est donc ça c'est quelque
chose qui a d'ailleurs profité en images
à emmanuel macron emmanuel macron était
très impopulaire en janvier 2019 et il
est capable cette tout ce qu'il a été
tout ce qui a été fait de hors jeu vidéo
du ministre jean yves et il en juillet
2009 un parent doit juste avant le
confinement est bien tout ça lui a
profité il a gagné une douzaine de
points quand même c'est pas un président
qui est partiellement impopulaire et il
dépasse 40% sur l'opinion donc quoi
qu'il en soit
il est nécessaire l'accord quoi je veux
transformer un tout petit pot votre
question c'est on peut s'interroger
parfois en disant mais c'est quand même
curieux que les français soient si
attentifs aux sujets sociaux lors de
l'élection présentielle alors même que
les écarts de revenus en france ne
s'accroisse pas c'est à dire que si vous
prenez le célèbre indice de gini on se
rend compte que ya pas d que les cartes
de patrimoine les écarts du patrimoine
s'accroît ce n'est pas justement ça ne
s'accroît pas en france parce que nous
avons un état social hyper puissant est
en réalité très efficace parce
qu'effectivement il ya une part énorme
de la richesse produite en france qui
est ensuite ou emprunté d'ailleurs qui
est ensuite redistribué et de manière
assez juste mais justement c'est pour
protéger ce système social que les gens
sont attentifs et vont voter parce qu'au
fond ce système social exclusivement du
pouvoir politique et donc à partir de là
ils veulent des garanties et ils sont
parfois inquiété par la philosophie
libérale qui tente à tort ou à raison
chez emmanuel macron et évoluer mais
pour l'instant il semblerait que
on se dirige vers une abstention
historique est elle n'est pas inévitable
cette abstention historique jérôme
sainte-marie a encore des leviers qui
peuvent là qu'ils peuvent inverser la
tendance mais plusieurs heures dans le
sondage challenge harris interactive
nous vous signaler j'ai vu très
rapidement ce qui est apparu aujourd'hui
mais il me semble il me semble qu'ils
assemblent de questions qui sont posées
sur l'intérêt pour la campagne sur le
jugement sur la campagne qui montre un
frémissement qui montrent que les gens
sont pas si a satisfait que cela de fait
notre temps de cerveau disponible si je
se dire par rapport à la politique à la
campagne en nous-mêmes qui sera restée
sur les plateaux on l'a bien vu bien
c'est assez de temps a été très
extrêmement réduit et c'est pas que la
campagne est déçu c'est qu'elle a été
occultée pendant assez longtemps
là ça sera une campagne très courte au
fond pour les européennes c'est aussi
des campagnes très courte et la plupart
des thèmes qui vont être traitées ont
déjà été abordés durant le quinquennat
je terminerai juste en disant que quand
il ya quand même des meetings réussi il
ya quand même des audiences aussi
importante donc il est fort possible que
nous remontions le la porte et que ça
sera peut-être certainement pas 78% par
six patients comme la dernière fois mais
le 69 % actuels à mon avis devrait être
dépassé en terme de participation donc
c'est ce que tous les aides tous les
ingrédients sont réunis pour qu'on les
gagne une forte abstention il ya quand
même une défiance et de la politique qui
est structurelle dans notre pays quand
on interroge les gens est ce que vous
faites confiance aux politiques et qui
s'aggrave et qui s'aggrave donc çà çà çà
çà c'est la brique de base là dessus
c'est vrai qu'on a eu une campagne qui
est quand même jugées décevantes et sans
grand intérêt des se vendent parce que
là pas aborder tous les thèmes auxquels
les français croyaient le pouvoir
d'achat est venu assez tard d'un
campagne beaucoup par l'immigration
beaucoup sécurité on voit aujourd'hui
que c'est des items qui sont pas
forcément en tête de leurs
préoccupations et sans intérêt parce
qu'elle a paru joué d'avancé vrai avec
la victoire annoncée programmé
pronostiqué des manèges macron dans tous
les sondages se rajoute encore une
couche au dessus qui est que certain
électorat qui se son sens qu'ils ne se
sentent pas concernés ou qu'ils sont
désorientés alors traditionnellement les
jeunes et là les jeunes sont parmi les
plus abstentionnistes en tout cas se
déclarent les plus susceptibles de ne
pas aller voter les catégories
populaires parce qu'elles ont
l'impression que rien ne change que on
reste toujours aussi pauvre est toujours
aussi avec un avenir toujours autant
boucher quel que soit le
président à l'elysée est une nouveauté
recond ressent beaucoup c'est les
déclarations d'abstention chez les
électeurs de gauche qui sont orphelins
qui sont perdus et ça c'est nouveau et
alors ce qui est nouveau c'est qu'il y
compris dans l'électorat de jean luc
mélenchon c'est l'avant ceux qui ont
voté jean luc mélenchon en 2017 dans
ceux qui ont voté benoît hamon en 2017
on trouve ils sont sur représentés par
rapport aux électeurs de françois fillon
aux acteurs de mad mâcon aux électeurs
de marine le pen ils sont sur
représentés comme s'il avait un peu à la
fois et perdu espoir et pas trouver
forcément le candidat qui leur convenait
et puis il ya peut-être une dimension
aussi vous l'avez évoqué j'aurais sapin
en parlant de temps de cerveau
disponible serre que
on est il ya des français qui
s'intéressent beaucoup moins que nous à
l'actualité et qui sont devenus des
consommateurs d'actualités un peu
contraint et forcé par la crise
sanitaire puis la guerre en ukraine etc
ont peut-être pas forcément là la
volonté de s'intéresser à la politique
ou la place de s'intéresser à la
politique et ça vient petit à petit tout
ça viendra petit à petit nom et d'un
yacht show que c'est vraiment une
dimension qui est intéressant je
voudrais notre regard d'historien
jean garrigues est ce qu'il y avait dans
les précédents de l'histoire de la vème
république des présidentielles oui on a
eu qui semblait comme ça un peu joué
d'avancé
oui il y en a eu et je dirais même
qu'elle a lui énormément à commencer par
les premières celle de 1965 où le
général de gaulle était largement favori
si bien qu'il n'a d'ailleurs pas fait
campagne et que qui s'est retrouvés en
ballotage oui au second tour alors qu'il
ne s'y attendait pas du tout cette
énorme déception pour lui et il a été
obligé été contraint à faire une sorte
de campagne avec des interviews avec
michel droit entre entre les deux tours
c'était à peu près pareil aussi en 1969
où la gauche était exsangue et où
finalement au second tour georges
pompidou grand favori s'est retrouvé
face à alain poher du centre est avec un
taux d'abstention là qui est un des
records de notre histoire qui est le
record de notre histoire sous là sous la
vème république ce qui veut dire entre
autres que les taux longs comment dire
la courbe de l'abstentionnisme elle
n'est pas linéaire est inéluctable elle
tient beaucoup aussi aux enjeux qui est
que vous avez au moment de d'un premier
ou d'un ou d'un second tour ça a été le
cas au premier tour de 2002 où vous
aviez l'impression là aussi qu'un duel
était inéluctable c'était celui de du
président de la république jacques
chirac et du premier ministre est le jeu
sports et là on est arrivé à une
abstention très très très forte ce qui a
permis d'ailleurs jean marie le pen
d'arriver au second tour donc il faut
bien voir aussi qu'il ya des des
circonstances particulières des enjeux
particuliers et d'ailleurs au fond dans
cette question de cette réflexion sur
l'abstention mais vous avez dire
énumérer tous les tous les aspects de la
question mais celui des des
différenciations de comportement et par
rapport au vote selon les catégories
sociales catégories populaires catégorie
plus diplômées catégories plus aisées
les jeunes face aux plus âgés c'est ça
qui va être déterminant on sait bien
d'ailleurs que marine le pen redoutent
une abstention qui serait trop forte de
son électorat jeunes populaires on n'est
pas du tout dans les mêmes circuits des
mêmes situations d'un d'un parti à
l'autre d'un candidat à l'autre et donc
je veux dire qu'il ya vraiment rien
d'inéluctable parce que là aussi si vous
permettez à les joueurs venir selon moi
je surveille toujours célibataire
rien mais revenir sur une idée reçue
aussi que l'on temps de paix questerre
que cette que cette campagne n'a pas
existé qu'elle était totalement mauvaise
qualité et la piètre guèye je suis pas
du tout d'accord avec ça je ne suis pas
du tout d'accord avec ça d'un point de
vue d'historien pourquoi entre autres
pourquoi parce que il y avait un
problème une question centrale qui
n'était pas assez revenu dans le débat
public et d'ailleurs c'est ce qui a fait
le succès des reds est mou mais toute la
pré campagne était occupé par eric
zemmour ces questions de sécurité
d'immigration sont des vrais enjeux
politiques des récents jeux de société
c'était important qu'on en parle ça a
été la précampagne les la question de
l'ukraine pose des problèmes mais qui
sont majeurs des problèmes de nos péchés
terminus et ou pas mais sur les affaires
étrangères sur la la la place de la
france dans l'europe la place sur les
relations internationales sur sur nos
relations avec les etats-unis le là
j'allais dire l'union soviétique la
russie donc ce sont des questions dont
il faut pas oublier que si on se réfère
aux institutions de la vème république
elles sont centrales pour désigner un
président de la république le général de
gaulle c'était le domaine réservé ce qui
l'intéressait c'était la défense les
affaires étrangères les relations
internationales donc donc vous dites la
campagne à spa était à pas énorme ces
questions non juste une remarque ces
questions en effet elles sont soulevés
par la guerre de l'ukraine par la gare
en ukraine elle était soulevé aussi par
la crise qu vide on les oublie aussi
vite donc c'est pas forcément parce
qu'elles sont soulevés qu'elles sont
forcément des battues très profondément
falcon 900 m je pense qu'il ya un grand
absent justement c'est emmanuel macron
dans cette campagne et sa fausse un
petit peu les choses les candidats
l'attendait loin longtemps attendu bon
c'est habituel ils ont longtemps attendu
comme candidat et maintenant qu'il est
candidat il s'échappe tout le temps il
n'est jamais là alors il est très
présent sur les réseaux sociaux sur les
épisodes télé surtout ce qu'ils
fabriquent il est triple il commence à
se déplacer mais il n'est pas là dans le
débat ça veut dire non et non mais on
reviendra la question est maintenant
j'ai une sainte marie bouillé intervenus
oui c'est injuste à voulait abondé aux
propos de de jean garrigues sur le fait
qu'il ya encore une fois pas de
tendances et de façades clint sur
l'abstention on a craint qualité de
fatalité et souvent on attend ça sur
interpréter ça en disant regardez cette
tendance au désalignement les dernières
européennes ont connu un sursaut de la
rénovation par exemple alors
qu'évidemment les régionales et
départementales c'était un effondrement
donc voyez il n'y a pas de et par
ailleurs effectivement il ya une légère
baisse de la participation lors des
trois dernières élections
présidentielles mais après un rebond en
2007 par rapport aux 28 % d'abstention
de 2002 et puis le choc du 21 avril que
dernière chose pour faire un peu
l'historien moi aussi eh bien regardez
c'est en ces temps on a eu entre 69 pas
en cinq rendez entre 69 74 puisque le
septennat de georges pompidou avait été
interrompue par sa mort est bien en 69
on a ce record d'abstention au second
tour de la présidentielle 31 % et c'est
une abstention politique c'est en plus
et tandis qu'en 74 on a le record de
participation parce que là c'est
l'opposition entre giscard et donc une
société libérale et celle de ce
programme creusement
allez on va dire trois modèles de ce
programme beaucoup plus radical que jean
luc mélenchon
est donc là il va un enjeu les gens se
mobilisent à ce moment là beaucoup je
vous propose d'entendre tout de suite
une réaction à propos de l' abstention
celle de philippe poutou le candidat
anti capitaliste est l'abstention elle
est complètement légitime en fait un il
ya un ras-le-bol depuis longtemps il ya
une situation de crise économique et
sociale terrible et puis sentiment
d'avoir toujours été baladé et trahi par
les élus qu'ils soient de gauche ou de
droite donc en fait aujourd'hui oui elle
ne grosse méfiance de la part des
institutions et puis il ya plus de
crédibilité dans les élections en tout
cas de moins en moins on en est même à
voter pour le moins pire impie même vous
avez eues on parle vachement du vote
utile on parle plus de votes de
confiance en fait donc il ya quelque
chose qui est très légitime qui
s'explique et voilà c'est un état de
fait c'est vrai que la présentielle
d'habitude il ya moins d'abstention
bella voilà on en arrive là puis en plus
macron qui veut pas faire débat il n'y a
pas de débat enfin la gestion de la
campagne la campagne présidentielle sans
confrontation enfin tout ça en rajoute
aussi a l'impression d'une élection qui
est déjà joué et puis les sondages qui
nous gavent tous les jours voilà il ya
plein de choses qui explique en fait les
choeurs n'en est le fait que les gens
s'éloignent de l'élection jérôme sainte
marie ils sont pâles de stratégie un peu
seul avec la question vous pour vous
pourrez répondre l'un et l'autre mais
c'est pas forcément est ce que c'est la
même stratégie quand on veut aussi dur
les abstentionnistes pour emmanuel
macron une marine le pen ou un jean luc
mélenchon non la plus menacée par
l'abstention ça a été dit c'est bien sûr
marine le pen puisque il ya quelque
chose qui ne change pas dans la
sociologie électorale depuis des
décennies depuis les très longtemps
travaux d'un larros clos du professeur
alain lancelot sur l'abstention c'est
les facteurs sociologiques et
démographiques de l'abstention plus on
est jeune plus moi on y le plot mais
plus on est pauvre et plus on s'abstient
tout simplement moi on est intégré au
groupe mois on a intégré à la cité et
moi on prend en charge les intérêts de
la cité c'est d'ailleurs l'origine du
suffrage censitaire au départ de faire
voter uniquement les propriétaires parce
qu'on considérait que seuls les
propriétaires avaient un intérêt
pratique aux affaires publiques donc
c'est pas le justifier le suffrage
censitaire que de le dire et donc
maintenant il ya ce qu'on appelle ça
c'est le professeur gaxie cette fois ci
le sens caché qui est justement le fait
que les classes populaires ont tendance
à ses limites elle même du scrutin
ensuite pour jean luc mélenchon il a une
petite fragilité sur l'abstention c'est
que certes il a beaucoup de
fonctionnaires les fonctionnaires votre
cinq points de plus que les salariés du
privé en général là aussi parce que ils
ont un rapport direct avec l'état et met
donc c'est plutôt un avantage pour lui
mais il a un petit problème c'est que il
a beaucoup de jeunes et notamment
d'étudiants qui sont intéressés par son
le vote en sa faveur or les étudiants
ils sont moins intégrés puis surtout il
souvent ils n'habitent pas l'endroit où
ils sont inscrits soit encore inscrit
dans leur domicile familial d'origine et
donc il ya une sur abstentions sur les
étudiants qui tient uniquement à ce
caractère de ma l'inscription dernière
chose pour celui qui a priori le plus
favorisé les deux qui sont plus
favorisés par une abstention
différentiel serait plutôt valérie
pécresse électorat retraités mais
retraités sa catégorie de très loin qui
votent le plus surtout quand ils sont
propriétaires et emmanuel macron tout
petit problème pour marc on sait que
beaucoup de ses électeurs pensent
peut-être que ça va être très facile de
ce point de vue là les sondages à tout
petit peu alarmants pour lui ma qui
donne un point d'écart le dernier
sondage est là bas je crois et bien au
second tour qui vont plutôt lui rendre
service en réveillant son électorat oui
c'est vrai que c'est l'une des infos du
jour on va on va consacrer un débat
là-dessus demain dans cette émission de
quoi ils passèrent à tout le monde mais
quand même le le le ce resserrement
entre emma les maquereaux et marine le
pen au premier et au second tour c'est
quand même une info importante oui ça
change un peu la donne est justement en
termes d'abstention ça peut changer
aussi la donne parce que ça devient
possible quelque part ce truc que
d'ailleurs eric zemmour disait
impossible eh bien ça devient vraiment
possible donc forcément pour qu'un pot
ça va me françois lisée ça va mobiliser
au delà de ce qu'on pouvait imaginer
c'est très risqué ce que je trouvais
intéressant dans le vous parliez de jean
luc mélenchon je trouve que sa stratégie
elle est intéressante aussi parce que
justement il se met face à emmanuel
macron et à marine le pen ils les
comparent beaucoup c'est comme sur un
bateau quoi il ya marine le pen emmanuel
macron il ya moi qui ai un projet de
société complètement différent et
sollicite justement cette opposition qu
on désespère de voir finalement parce
qu'on nous a vendu au début de la
campagne en effet l'immigration la
sécurité qui finalement au fil de l'eau
on était plutôt abandonné même si c'est
les préoccupations bellavance élu eric
zemmour la
pression j'aime ou like zemmour l'a
remis sur la table
valérie pécresse l'a suivie elle le suit
encore aujourd'hui ce qui ne sert
absolument à rien marine le pen en a
remis une couche mais très rapidement il
s'est remis sur le pouvoir d'achat on
nous a vendus ça donc je parle des
candidats surtout d'extrême droite et
puis finalement on a abandonné sa on
voit que c'est une préoccupation mais
c'est pas la première préoccupation des
français donc mélenchon et refait le
film en disant vous voyez bien que cette
france de droite et d'extrême droite
dont on nous parle tout le temps qu est
majoritairement à droite et ben c'est
pas vrai moi j'ai un projet de société à
gauche il est sollicité évidemment le
vote utile de ce côté là et il le
construit je suis opposé ses visions
contre vision la réforme de la retraite
60 ans pour moi 65 ans pour macron
l'école pareil il dit l'école la réforme
proposée par macron c'est une vision
très libérale c'est encore très
entreprenariale c'est la start up nation
qui est de retour et c'est pas du tout
ce canton qui vend vraiment modèles
différents et là ça peut solliciter des
gens dont vous parliez d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure de gauche un peu perdu un ski
votre un nouveau chacun peut-être qu'on
alors je sais pas ce que voulait dire
mais moi je voudrais bien vous entendre
l'un et l'autre sur marine le pen quand
vous serez pas là demain ça m'intéresse
d'avoir votre avis sur ce je vais
derniers sondages ans que marine le pen
incarne à la différence de jean luc
mélenchon qui n'a pas encore réussi à
incarner la dimension d'alternative
alors on y comprend n'y croit pas on se
fait peur on se fait pas peur mais
globalement dans cette campagne où elle
a fait preuve d'une résilience hors
normes on se prend résistants eric
zemmour en résistant la droitisation de
la droite et en
réussissant à prendre prendre le sujet
du pouvoir d'achat et d'en faire son nid
thème principal aujourd'hui l'alternance
c'est marine le pen dans l'esprit de
beaucoup jean luc mélenchon aimerait
beaucoup aidé dans cette position-là
l'huile un souci c'est qu'il a beaucoup
moins de réserves de voir puisque la
gauche est dans un état absolument
déstocker et lamentable et que du coup
les réserves de voix de jean-luc
mélenchon et sont précisément là où des
et jérôme sainte-marie dans l'abstention
mais aller chercher les abstentionnistes
et tout pari que font les insoumis pour
ça qu'ils disent on s'en fout parler aux
vieux socialistes on s'en fout de parler
aux écologistes ce qu'on veut aller
chercher c'est faire du porte à porte et
aller chercher des gens qui d'habitude
ne votent pas mais ça reste une
hypothèse évidemment
qu'ils ont c'est invérifiable c'est là
qu'on verra le jour du vote la dernière
fois comme jean luc mélenchon considère
qu'il est bon comme il considère que son
programme est bon c'était de la faute
des électeurs et c'est exactement ce
qu'il refait là il se dit non mais ça
explique structurellement la mentalité
la stratégie et je ne suis pas remise en
cause mon programme n'est pas remise en
cause c'est les gens qui n'ont pas voté
donc je vais aller les chercher est-ce
que la mobilisation des insoumis et on
voit que dans les meetings il ya du
monde qu'il ya des gens c'est vrai que
sainte-thérèse que les jeunes
s'intéressent il ne suffira pas à lui
donner cet élan pour lui faire à le
faire attraper et double éventuellement
marine le pen qui quand même est
vraiment dans une dynamique de campagne
très forte en fin de campagne d'habitude
elle fait toujours des des mauvaises
fins de campagne marine le pen là elle
en fait une canon alors canon on est
toujours le nez dans les sondages bien
évidemment et on verra la fin mais
si on regarde les dynamiques à son
discours s'est densifié son image c'est
lisse et gère après évidemment on est
d'accord ou pas d'accord est un domaine
mais on est obligé de reconnaître
qu'elle mène une campagne quand même
de belle façon jean garrigues votre avis
concernant la campagne de marine le pen
et et la tendance de ces derniers jours
matthieu croissandeau a tout dit ah bon
ben alors
à jouer mais c'est évident que jean luc
mélenchon est parti un peu tard me
semble-t-il pour crantée justement cette
cette idée d'un l'alternative il le doit
aussi à aux incertitudes qui planaient
sur la gauche parce que bon aujourd'hui
c'est pareil il paraît comme une
évidence qui vais le vote utile à gauche
mais au fond un moment donné on pouvait
penser que c'est m yannick jadot qui
prenaient l'ascendant si vous posez part
dans un torrent je posais une question
presque provocatrice est ce que marine
le pen fait une campagne de gauche et
est ce que c'est pour ça que quelques
années à ce niveau une campagne cachée
de la
provocation non mais sur le terrain
social incontestablement elle est plus
proche de jean-luc mélenchon et ceux
d'emmanuel macron est en tout cas que de
valérie pécresse donc on voit bien qu'il
ya quelque chose qui touche
effectivement un électorat populaire
mais c'est pas d'hier s'est passé
quelque chose qui dure depuis des années
et des années mais c'est une réalité
objective ce qui lui donne justement
cette capacité d'alternance
d'alternative et ce qui rend sa à sac sa
candidature crédible elle bénéficie de
la dédiabolisation que le 1 servir exe
moore sur un plateau ça fait beaucoup
d'éléments positifs pour elle a les
joues reprend la main on va parler de
nicolas sarkozy tout de suite nicolas
sarkozy qui ne sera pas au meeting de
valérie pécresse dimanche est l'une des
infos marquant de cette journée
politique alors on écoute bien pour
lancer cette séquence bruno retailleau
le président des sénateurs et l'air un
peu amer forcément logique puisqu'il
était un membre éminent de famille
politique pression de république c'est
de soutenir notre candidate voilà c'est
tout ce que j'ai à dire moi je me bats
au côté de valérie pécresse qui a montré
beaucoup de combativité
je trouve qu'elle a elle a eu un
traitement jeu de défaveur un peu
médiatique elle a fait l'objet de
beaucoup d'attaqués mais elle a du
courage
mathieu cette absence de nicolas sarkozy
dimanche au meeting de c'est pas
vraiment une surprise annoncée par an
une surprise parce que voilà des mois
que valérie pécresse et les républicains
attendent un geste une parole des mois
tu as rien devient entre ces deux là le
courant n'est jamais vraiment passé elle
n'a jamais fait partie du premier cercle
a été trop scolaire trop lisse pour
l'ancien président lui n'a jamais fait
partie de ces modèles à elle a été trop
bien trop bling-bling trop claniques
pour pour rennes qui fut sa ministre et
depuis qu'elle a été désignée candidate
les malentendus se sont succédé alors il
lui reproche de ne pas avoir eu assez
des gares pour lui lui qui se rêve
toujours en grand mamamouchi la droite
lui reproche de ne pas l'avoir écouté de
mener une mauvaise campagne est l'elbe
elle lui en veut évidemment de ne jamais
être venu en appui en aide en soutien à
un moment où elles en auraient eu besoin
et au moment actuel où elle en a encore
besoin elle n'aura droit à rien quand
françois fillon souvenez-vous lui avait
eu droit en plein naufrage et alors même
qu'il avait été le rival victorieux de
nicolas sarkozy lors de la primaire de
la droite il avait eu un soutien
explicite à quelques jours du premier
tour dans ce silence il étonne je
rappelle quand même qu'il n'est pourtant
ni à qui n'est automatique après tout
les ex ont toujours le sentiment que ce
qui leur succès de son soin des
imbéciles pour reprendre la phase de
clemenceau soit en tout cas jamais digne
de prendre leur suite mitterrand n'avait
pas eu un gros bond jospin en 1995
voulait pompidou voilà et souvenez-vous
chirac avait soutenu que sarkozy en 2007
mais pas en 2012 il avait préféré
françois hollande et puis c'est un
secret de polichinelle nicolas sarkozy a
appris à apprécier emmanuel macron qui a
su mettre les formes lui en le recevant
en faisons tout ce qu'il fallait alors
quelles conséquences silence pâti
d'avoir alors sur un compagnon de
valérie pécresse peu parce que d'abord
un soutien affiché ne suffirait pas à la
relance et elle est trop en difficulté
troppo retard trop loin regardez de
l'autre côté de l'échiquier politique le
soutien de françois hollande anne
hidalgo absolument eu aucun effet
ensuite parce que lui nicolas sarkozy il
est aussi l'âme un peu trop démonétisé
un à la fois par ses défaites
électorales successives en 2012 puis à
la primaire évidemment par ses ennuis
judiciaires qui n'en font pas vraiment
un talisman de la victoire mais ce
silence il aura en revanche les
conséquences un petit peu plus loin que
la présidentielle et des répercussions
sur la recomposition
venir de la droite au lendemain du
scrutin est-ce qu en ne soutenant pas
valérie pécresse nicolas sarkozy fait
preuve une forme d'ingratitude c'est ce
que disait bruno retailleau s'arrête la
droite l'a tellement soutenue dans tous
ces ennuis dans tous ces soucis que
c'est quand même un peu ingrat mais lui
nicolas sarkozy qui avait dit toujours
dit qu'il serait fidèle à sa famille
politique mais il monte ça monte son
silence montre aujourd'hui qu'il n'y
croit plus que d'une certaine façon les
républicains tels qu'ils existent
aujourd'hui c'est fini alors on n'y
reste pas non plus la une surprise on
s'en doutait un petit peu mais c'est une
façon de précipiter l'implosion que
cette figure majeure est magistrale de
la droite ne prennent même plus la peine
de soutenir la candidate la seule
question qui reste c'est comment tout ça
va se reconstruire pour la suite est-ce
que ce silence de nicolas sarkozy une
façon de jeter l'épongé avec le chacun
qui reprend ses billes et qui par les
hanches et zemmour les autres chez
edouard philippe oué oué alors est ce
que quelque chose se reconstruit autour
de quoi de quel programme c'est à voir
mais vraisemblablement plutôt dans
l'orbité de la majorité présidentielle
et elles sont là autour de qui et ben
nicolas sarkozy par des événements
évidemment c'est à dire on peut voir un
parallèle entre nicolas sarkozy et
françois hollande se font selon aussi
son discours il apporte son soutien
lagos en train aux constructeurs de
je ne sais pas quoi parce que qu'est ce
qui restera du ps on verra bien mais en
tout cas il se pose en reconstructeurs
jérôme sainte marie c'est effectivement
l'avenir de l air qui se joue est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec mathieu quand il
dit que nicolas sarkozy on a déjà fait
le deuil finalement de cette structure
telle qu'elle existe oui enfin pouvoir
également qu'il ya le lien entre la
droite classique et nicolas sarkozy
n'est très abîmée depuis la primaire de
la droite et du centre de 2016
appelez-vous d'ailleurs way au départ
ils étaient favoris ensuite il a parlé
lui aussi du vote cacher il va vous de
clichés dans cette primaire pour lui bon
comme souvent les votre cash et il est
pas se cacher l'odeur et ensuite il a
quand même été éliminé au premier tour
c'était quand même une blessure
d'orgueil dont est un révélateur quand
même d'un affaiblissement beaucoup plus
grand en réalité que des observateurs
voilà c'est quelqu'un qui vivait sur sa
réputation et qui en fait quand ça c'est
à l'épreuve du feu ça s'est pas révélée
très puissant là ça risque d'être la
même chose d'autant plus qu'il va avoir
un petit souci nicolas sarkozy ça sera
peut-être l'entre-deux tours dans
l'entre-deux-tours cissé macron le pen
il risque d'être appelé fortement par
emmanuel macron pour avoir pour qu'ils
appellent à soutenir pour avoir une
majorité aussi pas pour climat macro
puisse l'emporter dit qu'elle va
l'emporter le plus largement possible et
donc si il appelle à voter macron entre
les deux tours sans avoir appelé à voter
pour le corps de la candidate de droite
avant le premier tour ça ne fera
qu'aggraver la crise de l air si l'on va
continuer à se projeter sur l'avenir de
la droite mais je voudrais vous entendre
et mise à part ce qui sûr
la campagne de valérie pécresse
finalement il ya cette phrase de jacques
chirac les zambiens de ça vole toujours
en escadrille et depuis plusieurs jours
à la fin on a vraiment l'impression que
les fils les tuiles s'accumulent pour
rallier pks mais quelle part vous donnez
à
voilà à sa propre responsabilité
et puis
sarkozy c'est difficile aussi de donner
un petit peu son aval pour une femme
quoi faire la suite ça serait une femme
je pense que c'est compliqué pour
nicolas sarkozy c'est sur le terrain si
deux at il donné peut-être probablement
ce
que j'ai vu ce nom mais de proximité
poli mais parce qu'ils ont des liens oui
en effet depuis longtemps mais là là je
pense qu'il ya eu les deux il ya eu il
ya eu un beau collectif quand même
pendant la primaire il ya eu un
engouement il ya eu quelque chose qui
existait on voyait que ça intéressait
d'ailleurs aussi les gens il y avait des
idées c'est vrai qu'eric ciotti y était
pour beaucoup parce qu'il a beaucoup
dégainer sur ces questions dont ont
parlé d'immigration et de sécurité avec
un style très propre ce qui fait et qui
était plutôt bien et donc ils ont dit et
puis avait la perspective pour une
équipe potentiel tout à fait pouvoir
depuis dix ans on va peut-être y arriver
et mais ils ont pas du tout joué
collectif derrière ça et valérie
pécresse n'a pas réussi à incarner cette
chef que peut-être rachida dati aurait
fait c'est à dire de taper sur la table
et de dire moi je vais pas faire le
compromis entre tout le monde ce qu'elle
a essayé de faire est allé voir eric
ciotti est à voir hervé morin elle a
essayé de faire la paix je donne le
compromis si l'on fait aux ils ont fait
un collectif vraiment très très léger et
elle n'a pas su s'imposer après moi je
pense quand les prix la chance de la
question
sa part de responsables je continue à
dire qu'il ya en effet un petit peu de
machisme ambiant même si en effet
valérie pécresse n'a pas été bonne a du
mal à imposer une personnalité propre et
en miroir je mettrais marine le pen
parce que otan ça me fait mal de dire ça
d'une personnalité d'extrême droite mais
c'est vrai qu'elle incarne une
personnalité féminine politique dont on
ne pose plus la question du tout elle
elle incarne quelque chose de nouveau
côté féminin et on remet pas en question
ce mathieu et ensuite j'arrive rip que
ça m'a réussi je pense qu'il ya une
erreur stratégique de
valérie pécresse c'était d'aller
chercher ses mots et pas d'aller
chercher macron ça c'est quand même un
premier une première responsabilité xam
brise en droitisant son discours ce
qu'elle incarne et pas forcément c'est
une première stratégique ans suite à une
erreur technique elle a confié sa
campagne patrick stefanini on en pense
ce qu'on veut mais ils ont conçu une
campagne à l'ancienne ce qu'ils
appellent par séquences alors on va
faire une séquence éducation puis
apprend la fin de séquence industrie
puis apprend à faire une séquence hors
jeu pas tout le monde s'en fiche
personne ne raisonnent comme ça vous
pouvez faire des déplacements éducation
sa
compagne elle imprime
ensuite pourquoi elle imprime plein
parce que le dernier péché c'est qui a
pas d'idée c'est qu'il n'y a rien de
neuf n'est rien de nouveau il est obligé
de ressortir le kärcher sarkozy et
travailler plus pour gagner plus
qu'est-ce qu'elle a inventé qu'est ce
qu'elle a apporté en quoi la résumer les
attentes d'aujourd'hui les français et
quelle solution elles leur a donné rien
axes les gens garé votre analyse alors
c'est aussi ce que ce que je m'apprêtais
à dire mais je vais le redire à ma
manière le ce qui fait le succès de
nicolas sarkozy en 2007 ces deux choses
c'est qu'il arrive à rassembler à
imposer son leadership sur la famille
des républicains d'ailleurs il prend le
leadership sur le l'ump en 2004 avant de
devenir avant de commencer la
candidature et les et deuxièmement
d'avoir su imposer une idée un projet
qu'on le veuille ou non c'est le projet
de 2007 n'est qu'un sarkozy là une
structure une cohérence il et on voit
très bien ce qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière
le goût du travail là le néolibéralisme
triomphant et c'est quelque chose
d'ailleurs qui est une des raisons de
cette faible taux d'abstention 2007 ça
fait parce que sacre en télé l'électorat
le problème de valérie pécresse c'est
d'une part et qu'elle n'a pas su
véritablement rassembler et surtout
qu'elle n'a pas donné d'identité
véritable c'est à dire que l'identité
qu'elle donne à sa campagne n'est pas la
sienne elle endosse un avis qui n'est
pas le sien elle fait une campagne comme
aurait pu la faire eric ciotti en tout
cas en soulignant beaucoup cet aspect là
alors qu'elle est en fait une
technocrate libéral qui est en réalité
on passe le ce le cachet très beau
beaucoup plus proche des manuels macron
que de que d'eric zemmour ou codées
risqués et donc c'était plus compliqué
pour reprendre lorsque ce que disait
monsieur l'air d'aller chercher
l'électorat d'emmanuel mâcon peut-être
pas elle en était trop de moyens mais
elle est surtout le symptôme d'une
droite divisée qui n'a pas trouvé
justement de vecteur de rassemblement
d'une droite qui étaient quittes qui
était car tollé depuis depuis très
longtemps et qui n'a pas trouvé son sa
ligne de conduite est alors justement
jérôme sainte-marie ça pose la question
de du post élections pour des des poids
lourds de lr aujourd'hui je sais pas je
pense au frère ennemi xavier bertrand et
laurent wauquiez qu'est ce qu'ils vont
faire au soir du premier sans doute du
premier tour ce convoi plus maintenant
valérie pécresse rattraper son retard
alors la droite à une situation
paradoxale parce que il faut toujours
rappeler que la droite a remporté les
élections au niveau musical oui c'est à
dire que la france a soutenu la réforme
n'ont réussi à s'implanter aux
départementales ou régionales ou
municipales oui mais ça le leur qui a
empêché le ps de travailler mais là des
années à la politique les élections la
politique allait elle y compris parce
que c'est là où il ya des postes
électifs des collaborateurs etc c'est
clame à ce niveau là que ça se passe en
fait par ailleurs ces on-dit ils n'ont
pas travaillé mais la droite comme la
gauche classique sont victimes c'était
un peu diam instants du fait qu' il ya
maintenant un produit que ce produit de
synthèse qui s'appelle le maquereau
nisme qui est issu finalement deux des
politiques publiques suivies par la
gauche comme par la droite dont est donc
le problème qu'avait marie valérie
pécresse pour au début de campagne
c'était de savoir si c'était une
créature d'opposition très difficile
parce que 40 % au moins des
sympathisants de droite ont une bonne
image des manuels macron c'est qu'au
bout de cinq ans donc c'est très
difficile et ça peut être plutôt une
poignée taux de substitution en disant
je vais faire mieux que moi ou pouvoir
il est usé etc je dépenserai - je fais
plus attention aux finances publiques je
vous garantis que raphaël sauf que là
arrivent en plus l'ukraine et donc il ya
un réflexe de solidarité autour du
président de la république et puis deux
fêtes pour quelqu'un qui résonne avec
les critères d'un électeur de droite
classique et bien il n'y a pas tellement
de prise du ram à l'action des manuels
macron donc c'est quelque chose de très
durable est ce que je veux finir juste
par là est ce que ce sera des
conséquences très graves après a forcé
va forcément parce que c'est le dernier
quinquennat et confond vous savez pour
un élu local
rien n'est plus faveur plus confortable
que d'être dans l'opposition donc je
pense que la machine ne se passe quoi
devenir le groupe de droite mais par
contre la machine de la rue de gérard
lui parfaitement tenir allez on va
terminer autour de la campagne des
macros la question des ralliements le
savoir ce que vous en pensez on aura peu
de temps mais on va aller vite et mal
mâcon qui a réussi à attirer à la fois
des personnalités de droite comme jean
pierre raffarin ou alors
un élu de gauche comme françois rebsamen
le maire de dijon chez qui le candidat
président s'est rendu lundi à regarder
cette séquence qui voulez vous qu'on ait
aujourd'hui à part emmanuel macron c'est
pas dévaloriser lui-même et les autres
mais il s'est à chef d'état il est
compétent et moi je considère qu' il est
de notre devoir d'être derrière lui de
gauche du centre gauche de la droite du
champ très droit derrière lui pour faire
cette france unie en soit observé nos
micros de quentin a calmé et jonathan
dupriez emile isabelle ski que pc
ralliement rien alors je pense pas que
ça pèse rien n'a pas personnellement mon
françois rebsamen il a mis un petit peu
de temps mais c'est pas personnellement
chacun c'est dans cet esprit que macron
incarne un peu de la gauche un peu de la
droite et que finalement il a aspiré
côté valérie pécresse il a aspiré côté
parti socialiste en tout cas en 2010 est
donc c'est ça qui fait cet effet mais
alors après quand on regarde ce que
sacrée parce que c'est un produit vous
l'avez dit c'est un produit macro et on
le voit bien dans sa stratégie de
communication qui est plus proche d'une
des politiques marketing que font les
entreprises ou de politique de marque
d'image de marque que d'un véritable
parti politique c'est à dire qu'on a un
bel emballage on a des belles choses
très très bien fait on a une machine de
guerre qui emploie beaucoup de cabinets
privés d'ailleurs et et les ministres en
train de s'en occuper parce qu'ils
sentent que ça monte aussi cette
histoire de michaels et ce sera un thème
de débat demain
cette conférence de presse la qui vit
aujourd'hui en charge et des ministres
et débat autour de ces pauvres nous est
ce que je veux dire c'est que c'est un
peu vide et si on enlève emmanuel macron
de ce chapeau gauche droite qu'est ce
qui reste c'est la colonne vertébrale
c'est le dénominateur commun microns
après les règles en place ils ont
beaucoup de choses à colin delà de la
conclusion moi c'est cette impression
que que la campagne un peu en surplomb
est en train de le plomber emmanuel
macron ça c'est une certitude que
les prisonniers de cette image de
président en campagne et qu' il n'a pas
suffisamment et ne pas encore
insuffisamment les sur le terrain mais
on peut imaginer que le meeting du 2
avril pourrait lui servir comment
dirais-je deux dernières rampes de
lancement juste avant l'élection est ce
qu'il faudrait qu'ils descendent comme
proxy musée on apprenne qu'il aille
prendre des coups tout simplement ça
c'est une question aussi de perception
parce que lui il peut considérer aussi
qu'il a fait un certain de il a fait une
conférence de presse il talent et il
était la rencontre des français je sais
plus à dijon il ya donc il ya aussi mais
il est évident qu'avec cette campagne il
a choisi lille a choisi celle du
président chef de guerre donc c'est
c'est quand même compliqué en même temps
d'avoir une campagne de presse et pas
une campagne qui ressemble à celle de
2017 mais je rappelle que la campagne de
françois mitterrand en 1988 et pas du
tout la même que celle de 1980 c'est pas
du tout le changer la vie c'est la
génération mitterrand et que celle de
jacques chirac en 2002 n'est pas du tout
celle de 1995 donc finalement il ya une
certaine c'est à dire presque une
cohérence historique à avoir une
campagne aujourd'hui qui est très
différente de de la précédente
maintenant je pense pas que cela soit
uniquement un produit c'est je pense
c'est la concrétisation d'un projet
politique qui vaut ce qu'il vaut mais
cette alliance est à droite et à gauche
au fond c'est l'aboutissement de la
victoire d'une forme de social
libéralisme qui ce qui se dessinait déjà
depuis 15 ans dans la société française
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat je rappelle jean le
titre de votre livre la tentation du
sauveur livre qui est publié aux
éditions payot